- [Instructor] We are told
a teacher bought 12 sheets
of stickers to use on the
homework of her students.
Each sheet had 48 stickers.
At the end of the year,
the teacher had 123 stickers remaining.
Which is the best estimate
for the number of
stickers the teacher used?
So like always, pause this
video, and see if you can
have a go at this before
we work on this together.
All right, now let's
work on this together.
So the first thing to appreciate is
we just have to figure out an estimate.
We don't have to figure
out the exact number
of the stickers that were used.
Let's see if we can do that.
So let's see,
we have 12 sheets of stickers,
and each sheet had 48 stickers,
48 stickers per sheet.
So how many stickers did
the teacher start off with?
Well, there were 12 sheets
times the number of stickers
per sheet, so times 48,
times 48.
This is going to be the number
that they started off with,
number to start.
And then if we want to figure
out the number that are used,
we just have to figure out, okay,
from the number that was
started, how many are left over?
And then that's how many were used.
And so how many were left over?
Well, 123 were remaining
at the end of the year,
so that's this number right over here.
So if we calculate that
first, the number to start,
we subtract out the
number that are remaining,
then that will be equal
to the number of stickers
that the teacher used.
Now once again, we don't
have to figure out exactly.
We just have to estimate.
And so I'm just going to try
to figure out friendlier
numbers to work with.
So instead of 12, let's imagine,
let's imagine, actually,
I'll stick with 12.
12 I can work with.
But let's say that this is going
to be approximately equal to,
so in parentheses, instead of 48,
I'll say it's roughly 50.
So this is going to be
approximately 12 times 50.
Instead of 123, I'll say that's roughly,
a friendlier number might
be 120 or might be 100.
Let's just do 120, so minus 120.
We could've done 100.
And so we could figure out
what this is in our heads
or with a little bit of paper.
12 times five is 60,
so 12 times 50 is 600.
And then 600, if we had 100 here,
600 minus 100 would've been 500,
or 600 minus 120 is 480.
So what we want to do
is look at the choice
and see which of these choices is closest
to roughly 500 or roughly 480?
And so let's see, out of all of these,
actually they have exactly 480, which is,
so they estimated exactly the
way we happened to estimate.
Now not every person is going to do that.
We could've chosen,
instead of 123 becoming
120 in our estimate,
we could've put 100 there, and
then we would've gotten 500.
But even if 500 was our estimate,
480 still would've been the
closest to that estimate.